Whether you eat it or not, you must have heard of gluten. Especially with increased interest in gluten-free diet.
Many people wonder what gluten is, and more specifically do you have to
Should you eat it or not?
Simply put, gluten is a compound of two proteins that are found mainly in wheat and similar grains
Such as barley and rye. Just ! It's just a protein! These two types of protein are called Glidine
Glutinin is a combination of gluten, which helps nourish plant embryos
An essential source in giving bread to its usual lyce in chewing, just like
Gum, making the dough is similar in its properties to the sponge!
Well, why is gluten bad for us? In fact this is not true, gluten itself is not harmful or essential
For your health, there is not enough evidence that stopping it is considered
A good choice for a healthy person. In contrast, people with chronic digestive disorders -
Called "celiac disease" - can not eat gluten at all, which caused the misunderstanding
When some
The body of a person with celiac disease sees gluten as something exotic on the human body, leading to an immune response
Eventually leading to the destruction of a small part of the intestines. By repeating this, the body becomes infected
Severely undernourished. Newly discovered scientists
Some people who are not sick with Celiac disease have an allergy to gluten
They suffer from similar symptoms after eating gluten - such as intestinal cramps, diarrhea and abdominal distension.
In both cases, gluten free food is essential. But if you
Do not suffer from any of the two conditions, there is no significant difference in health if the follow gluten-free diet.
Gluten is not by any means toxic as some people think, as well as gluten free food does not necessarily mean
It is healthier food or less in calories.
By contrast, there is some risk in the absence of gluten, although the absence of gluten itself
Is not in itself a problem, but the absence of vitamins and the accompanying pills may be dangerous.
Without getting them, it may be harmful to your health. Most importantly,
Without the gluten to keep your food connected, more fat and sugar will be used to compensate gluten when making gluten-free foods
So as to make them delicious.
At the same time, the popularity of diets based on gluten-free foods has created a market for this
Type of foods. Previously there were limited options for this type of food, while now we find multiple options of gluten-free foods,
Which is good for people in need of this kind of food!
But what if there is a substance that contains all the things your body needs, and excludes
Everything you do not need? Something similar to "ideal diet"? Come with us to
Our second channel is ASAPTHOUGHT, where we will analyze in detail how you will never need in the future
To worry about getting your food! Click here on the screen, or on the link in the description below!
Do you have an urgent question? Ask us in the comments section or our Twitter and Facebook pages.
If you would like to see exclusive coverage of the ideas of upcoming episodes as well as scenes behind the scenes,
Go to our page on Instagram.
As well as subscribe to our YouTube channel to get more videos weekly!